with chance similar to those that rang
out during the start of anti-government
protests last year this train takes off
from the Sudanese capital Khartoum to a
place nicknamed the city of steel and
fire where the revolution started a year
ago while those in Khartoum marks its
first anniversary the same way they
started every demonstration last year
with the singing of the national anthem
we proved how resilient they can be and
how strong they are and how can they
stand up to anything using their
creative power and their creative energy
and their determination and resilience
through tough times
it all began over the high prices of
bread in the northeastern city of add
button within hours it spread to other
cities and soon turned nationwide people
demanded the resignation of President
Omar al-bashir who had governed for
nearly 30 years
they also called on his entire
government and ruling party to go the
military deposed Bashir in April and
following months of political turmoil
filled with determination and
persistence to see change by
demonstrators the military hunter and
protest leaders reached a power-sharing
deal in August and then from the
transitional government Sudan's
revolution has been costly in terms of
lives these pictures show just some of
those killed during protests over the
posture of months and even though Bashir
and his government are gone and a new
transitional one is then demonstrators
who demanded change say their revolution
is far from over
activists say more than 250 protesters
were killed since the start of the
protests half of that during an attack
on a pro-democracy sitting on June 3rd
and 12 month on in a revolution where
people called for freedom peace and
justice the demand for justice has taken
a front seat we want retribution for
those killed they've given their lives
for change to happen and it's because of
them were able to celebrate today the
transitional government has set up a
committee to look into those allegations
the government also disbanded the former
ruling party in line with some of the
demands made by the people the sudanese
professional association which led the
calls for protests as much work remains
after all this all this progress we're
still out there still shouting for
freedom we salute shopping for justice
or celebration fight shouting and
demanding peace and we think that we've
come a long way and we still have a long
way to go it's it's just a matter of
time so for now people here examine and
reflect on what they've achieved so far
while making it clear that they still
want to see more being done to complete
their evolution
Kiba Morgan al Jazeera Curtin